a family's home gone in seconds Swept
Away by a swollen River after days of
heavy rain
Cyclone yaku has left a trail of
Destruction and displaced hundreds of
families in Northern Peru since making
landfall last week
I have nothing my daughters are left in
the street we need help we don't have
water food nothing
[Applause]
many didn't have time to salvage any
belongings before their homes were
washed away
when I stepped out of my house the whole
area was full of smoke from falling land
I went back inside and told my son get
up the river will sweep us away we tried
to take our clothes but there was no
time the water swept everything away
the government's declared a state of
emergency in 400 districts and issued
Landslide warnings in nearly 600
president Dina buluate visited some of
the hardest hit areas as authorities
delivered much needed Aid
and painful families are trapped in the
mud rice crops are flooded and you can't
even see the path of the river it's lost
this can't continue
[Applause]
the Cyclone is the latest crisis to hit
Peru they've been widespread
anti-government protests since Congress
removed then-president Pedro Castillo
from power in December
but for those who've lost everything as
a result of the Cyclone their attention
is focused on more immediate problems
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera